[Music]
look okay it's not my fault
I bet nothing's ever your fault is it
darling you have thrown away your life
working in some silly Christmas shop
this is my little helper I have
nicknamed her lazy that out because she
appears never to walk so they really are
just kidding what Jesus what's your
comfort well what are you looking at -
oh I think I just peed in your eye yeah
I think so it's good luck you know what
is impudent mother I'm busy you're weird
good bye
you've missed five doctor's appointments
mum is scared so tell me about the sleep
exercise at all alcohol
oh she's little like the pirate okay
fine thank you doctor thank you so much
for your time let's go again you mean
again did you follow me here are elves
always so cynical
yes relentlessly these are dark times
I'm Tom Kate will you murder me so what
is it that you do I sing oh it's amazing
anyway boring boring boring I'm gonna
board
where are you going when that well
you're not homeless
no I volunteer why didn't you just get
saved I do - no forehead you looked
great at your job when you started right
now it's like you don't care anymore
yeah hi hi Kyle I'm a mess I was really
sick and I nearly died but I told people
cuz they get weird but I don't think
you'll get wet no I'm just scared all
the time and they just expect me to be
normal okay always like there's no such
thing as normal it's just being a human
being is hard maybe you should do
something nice for someone deck the
halls with boughs of holly fa la la la
la la la la la tis the season to be
jolly oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
- volunteering the shelter seriously
I sauce like a healthy choice what's
wrong with you I've been trying to find
you you keep disappearing lemon I do
bump into you accidentally I might add
it wasn't accidental
[Applause]
why me it's always good over here like
I'm gonna make mistakes and that's okay
you're made of everything you do
[Music]
[Music]